I wanted to make sure that everyone
realized that anybody can work with the
deaf person and as a deaf person I can
work with anybody Dancing with the Stars
contestant model nyle DiMarco absolutely
stunned on Monday his Viennese Waltz
with switch up partner Sharna Burgess
was so moving it left many in tears
okay
um you take my breath away it's the best
dance of the night eight Fang the magic
of dance is alive within you Niles
original partner Peta Murgatroyd got
emotional over his stellar performance
which earned the 26 year old a score of
37 out of 40 and got the best dance of
the week so I'm happy with that
other standouts included ginger Z's
salsa with Mark Ballas Paige vans dance
rumba with Sasha Farber wanye Morris's
tango with Whitney Carson and Jody
sweetens Paso Doble with Val
Chmerkovskiy going into tonight I was
ready I was calm I was prepared I had a
partner that really you know pushed me
and worked me really hard this week and
by the time I got out there on the floor
tonight it was like it was me and him it
was fantastic